uh all right hey I'm Carl ritger
um and I'm at the national snow and ice
Data Center and The Institute of Arctic
and Alpine research at the University of
Colorado Boulder what you see here is
the red outline is the
Bay Area sort of the interquartile range
or the middle 50 percent along with the
driest and wettest years at the top and
the bottom in the median year in the
Middle with the blue line here and this
point at the very end showing this
year's conditions and I should say that
these conditions for the wettest and
driest are chosen uh from the years with
the wettest and driest Across the
Western ufs not specific for this Basin
so we could have a slightly lower or
higher year on those but they're pretty
good proxies generally the snow-covered
area summarize over
24 hours and then the percentage of mean
so what equivalent and I usually use
that bottom one the percentage of means
so I'll click that on now you can see
this color bar has two colors on it one
for the snow cover which is the
underlying map and one for Suite which
is on the top there
and
um you know what you what you see here
is that you know on the western portion
of the Upper Colorado into Utah there we
have very high values and this color bar
only goes up to 150 percent so we're
sort of saturating our color bar there
the other things we can look at and I'm
going to use this can
to sort of add a bunch of data to the
map here so you can view a whole bunch
of variables snow covered days is
basically a duration of snow cover
snow radiative forcing tells us the
impact of dust and snow on the snowpack
it melts faster when there's more sorry
dust and carbon when there's more dust
and carbon on the snowpack it melts
faster and then snow Albedo is just that
brightness of the snow so now I've sort
of set those so the top graph here was
the snow cover
and then we have snow covered duration
or snow covered days here so you can see
that
um you know we're doing well above the
75th percentile again this is a summary
graph
showing you know compared to the
previous 22 years from the satellite
record
Colorado gets a lot of dust uh in the
San Juans so we have the radiative
forcing map here uh you can see that
right now I'm looking compared to the
averages we're sort of at the we've got
the cleanest snowpack or the least dust
uh impact from you know on the on the
snow energy balance and if you look at
the snow Albedo as well you sort of see
that same thing with high Albedo values
meaning it's reflecting a lot of the
sun's uh solar radiation
um so yeah that's kind of the the set of
data that we have available on here we
bring together the satellite derived
maps of snow cover snow cover days
radiative forcing and Albedo along with
the sweet Point measurements from the
snotel stations